so most of these top three programming
languages videos they always start off
by saying it depends because blah blah
blah I won't say that I'm just gonna
give two so the top three programming
languages depends where you're trying to
optimize for Wow
what a hypocrite anyways this video is
sponsored by skill share so I've bucket
it into three main categories or like
main purposes for learning a new
language and I think that encompasses
most of you now I want you guys to be
honest with yourself because I do think
that 95% of you guys who say that you
want to go into computer science because
it is your passion
you are lying to yourselves now that 95
percent they actually care about money
the lifestyle or the promise that you'll
be able to build a startup that will
make you billions now that is totally
fine because there's nothing wrong in
choosing a career for its financial
advantages that is called
making informed life decisions but don't
lie to yourself be honest because or
else you might end up hating what you do
but if you're honest with yourself
you'll understand the trade-off that you
made and you accept the setbacks and the
negative outcomes of your life also
don't feel bad that you suddenly realize
they're lying to yourself I've lied to
myself many times I lied to myself
saying that I want to be a doctor when I
was 13 because it was my passion to help
other people get better but obviously as
Asians we all know what the true reason
we want to be doctors so that we can
touch boobies right alright so now that
you're honest for yourself put yourself
in one of these three camps one I want
to program because I want a tech job at
a big tech company too I want to program
because I want to build web apps fast so
that I could make my own product or work
for an early startup 3 I want to program
so that I could be ahead when I start
computer science next year as a freshman
I also make one assumption you haven't
programmed that much or you are a
beginner because I don't think most
experienced programmers care about the
top languages they know that most
languages are kind of similar and what
they care about is more
about what frameworks or engineering
domain they should focus on
alright so depending on which camp
you're in I'm going to give you the top
three programming languages now I'm
going to give those to you so that once
you start learning stuff that's actually
important like engineering domains or
frameworks you don't need to relearn
these languages so that at least you can
get that out of the way
for example imagine if your goal was to
do machine learning or play with data
and fit some models then I would say you
should go with Python but learning
Python has nothing to do with learning
machine learning but it's just that once
you get to machine learning most
probably you will use the language
Python because of the frameworks like pi
torch and stuff like that alright so
let's start with I want to program
because I want a tech job at a big tech
company now before we go into that I
want to tell you how the recruiting
process works at these big tech
companies you have three stages right
the first one is to get an interview and
then the second stage is to pass the
interview and then the third stage is to
do well in your job aka not get fired
ask yourself what is my limiting factor
is it that I can't get the interviews or
is it that I can't pass the interviews
or is it that once I get the job I'm not
doing very well and I don't like it so
think of it as a funnel and understand
what your limiting factor is and then
work on that if your resume is not
picked up by d interviewer then it
doesn't matter how great of a software
engineer you're because you're never
gonna get to that bottom of the funnel
you're never gonna get to start working
then there's no chance for you to show
off your awesome software engineering
skills that's just how life is
unfortunately so if your limiting factor
is not being able to get interviews then
that means you have to work on your
resume and if you'll have to work on
your resume it means you have to have
work experience there but you can't have
work experience if you've never gotten a
job so the alternative is getting
referrals and in combination having good
personal projects for your resume
however if your problem is that you
can't pass the interviews then that
means you just have to up
your data structure and algorithm skills
and that means Li coding especially for
these big tech companies because that's
what they test you on if your problem is
that you can't do your job well once you
get in there then most of the time it's
not because there are technical
abilities but it's more about your
resourcefulness and how independent I am
kind of skills alright so here's the top
three languages for beginners who want
to eventually get into a big tech
company doing a tech job so number one
Python number two Java and number three
C++ these three languages are the best
for big tech companies during coding
interviews and that is what you should
be optimizing for if you have to put
time into one thing then I strongly
recommend that thing to be leak coding
many people have been able to get into
jobs like Facebook or Google just by
being good at solving these leak code
questions even though some of them might
not even know what git is or build files
are crazy now for interviews I think
using Python is your best bet because it
is not typed you don't need to do memory
management and there are a lot of
shortcuts that make it easier for you to
code during your interview and that is
extremely important because each line of
code if you save about one or two
seconds that adds up to a lot and also
you don't need to use your brain to
think about the syntax or particular
language stuff so that you have more
time or more space in your brain to
think about the actual problem itself
Python is also really good because many
of the web frameworks like Django and
flask are in Python and these frameworks
are really good for you to make personal
projects and these projects will
translate well into your resume to get
interviews I put Java and C++ there
because I guarantee you that a big tech
company at least one part of their
system is written in Java or C++ C++ is
usually used for more complex systems
when performance is really important
Java less so but it's a great language
to build applications
like for example LinkedIn uses it to
sigmah uses it Palantir uses it now yes
I put Java and C++ below Python but they
do have one thing over Python your
curriculum at school is probably using
Java or C++ most universities I don't
think they will teach in Python because
Python is not a great language to learn
fundamentals like types or you know
building and compiling and memory
management you don't need that in Python
so that's why they preferred not to
teach those things in Python because
python is an interpreted language if you
don't understand what that means don't
worry about it
because eventually you will that's how
we learn stuff we just hear we just hear
a lot of things that gets repeated to us
and over time we connect the dots and
then we realize oh that's what I meant
Python Java and C++ have tremendous
support in lis code usually when they
give you answers or solutions to the
problems they give it to you in these
three languages yeah so then I put C++
below Java because C++ is a very wordy
language and that's gonna slow you down
during interviews so that's why C++ is
at third place all right so if your goal
is to build stuff like build web
applications and build them fast and
have fun with them then I think the top
three programming languages are
JavaScript Java and Swift this might be
a little bit controversial but I'll
explain it later now if you're like you
javascript is a trash language shut up
stop recursion tating what you've read
on the internet and have your own
opinions for Christ's sakes before I
explain why I chose these programming
languages let me explain how web apps
are built you have a front-end and then
you have your business logic in your
back-end and then you have storage for
your data that is usually how web apps
are formed to reiterate you have the
front end that displays [ __ ] to your
users and then you have the back end
that decides what to display depending
on your data that you have
and then you also have storage to store
your data for example if you're making
online tic-tac-toe then the front-end
you display the grid for the players to
interact with and then the backend you
have the logic of saying oh if that's
the case he wins if that's the case she
wins if that's the case that's a draw
and then on the data storage side you
store in memory or whatever the state of
the game all right so now that you
understand front-end and back-end of a
web app let me explain to you why I
think JavaScript is number one and also
why I said that my list was a little bit
controversial now I think my list is a
little bit controversial because python
is not in there python is extremely
popular for building backends for web
applications lamp stack was very popular
back then laughs is Linux Apache my
sequel and PHP and then PHP got replaced
by Python over time and Python became
very very popular so a lot of frameworks
like Django and flask made a popular I
actually use Django a lot back when I
was in college I built a website called
porn Dora but that's a story for another
time so yes
Python was really popular but then
Google released their v8 engine and then
also concurrently nodejs
came along which is a runtime
environment for JavaScript that caused a
bunch of web frameworks for JavaScript
to pop up for example express especially
because these web frameworks were so new
they were built with scale in mind older
frameworks didn't anticipate the scale
that we would be operating at so they're
at a disadvantage compared to the newer
sexier frameworks that optimizes on
throughput and scalability because of
their event-driven architecture capable
of asynchronous IO so using nodejs as
your back-end
is extremely popular for pet projects or
even startups now you know tinder uses
nodejs for their back-end if you know
what I mean knob I'm serious they
actually use node.js at
what's great about JavaScript is that
it's also good for front-end now you
know websites its built in HTML CSS and
JavaScript and then also front-end
frameworks and libraries you have react
and angularjs in addition even for
mobile apps
you now have react native where you can
build iOS app and Android app by using
JavaScript nodejs or I mean javascript
is the only language that you can solely
use to build a whole app and to end all
right next I put Java and Swift the
reason why I put Java and Swift is
because for mobile development you need
Java for Android and then you need Swift
for iPhones so as you can see I never
really talked about the specifics or the
features of a language if you are
watching this videos I highly doubt that
you would care about the intricacies of
a programming language what you should
care is how much support you have on the
internet for that language or purpose
you're trying to accomplish
for example C++ is a great language to
build performing systems but if you want
to do data stuff there isn't that much
popular support for data frame style
libraries so it's a crappy language if
you want to do data stuff now on the
other hand R is a great language for
numerical computation but if you want to
build web applications for it I don't
think you have that much support because
it's just not that popular to use art to
build web applications I'm pretty sure
someone made a web application framework
but if there aren't that many people who
use it then there isn't that much
support for it and then every time
you're gonna Google something you're not
gonna find the answer so before you jump
into a language and build a web app what
you should do is that you should build a
small project and then Google your way
through your answers and then if you
could see that Wow
every time I google something I get an
answer right away on Stack Overflow then
it means this language has a lot of
support and you should use it but if not
then not so much and then once you find
that that language is
probably the best for your use case
because you have the support of the
whole internet all right now for the
final bucket for you people who want to
get ahead
before starting computer science as a
freshman from what I understand what I
said before is that they usually use
Java or C++ for their courses for me
when I was in Waterloo the first
programming language they taught us in
was something called scheme which was a
functional programming language and then
later on they taught us using C not C++
C because they wanted to teach us memory
management so that we understand the
fundamentals of memory more and then
later on we used C++ so that we learned
about object-oriented programming and
then depending on your electives you
could usually use whatever you want
whatever that gets the job done
but mostly they make you use Java or C++
things that require high performance you
usually want a language that you could
compile into binary and then run it so
for example C++ is a very popular choice
for graphics and then C is a also very
popular choice for low-level things so
usually in OS classes or embedded
systems classes you're going to be using
C I personally like C++ more just
because I think once you learn the
language and the fundamentals of it it's
pretty easy to port over other languages
but that's just my opinion
but anyways that's pretty much it thank
you for listening peace out thank you so
much Skillshare for sponsoring this
video
Skillshare is an online community with
thousands of classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills
explore classes and everything like from
web development to freelance and
entrepreneurship to graphic design and
more premium membership gives you access
to high-quality classes from experts
working in their fields to help you gain
new skills and live your best life
secure share is also incredibly
affordable I mean
they have an annual subscription of less
than $10 a month I took a few of their
premium original classes and I was
pleasantly surprised by some of them and
this one especially the class is called
presentation essentials how to share
ideas that inspire action by simon Sinek
in case you don't know Simon's neck he
is an author and a motivational speaker
the first time I heard about him is from
a viral video where he talks about
Millennials in the workplace I thought
he was a great storyteller and for me I
think storytelling is an extremely
important skill to have this class is
short sweet and to the point and I
highly recommend checking it out so if
you're interested click on the link in
the description down below and you're
gonna get two months of premium
Skillshare for free check them out
[Music]